hello thank you very much uh for the
invitation to speak here i'm sorry i
can't be there in person i wish i could
um so i'm uh thank you to rago and leo
and everybody for inviting me to give
this talk so i'm going to be talking
about para parameter estimation for
undirected graphical models with hard
constraints
so
so i'm going to start with an
illustrative example which is what is
called the hardcore model
so you know you're given a graph
and i'm going to use the usual notation
the twiddles for neighboring vertices
and use d u
for the degree of the vertex u in the
graph g
an independent set
is a subset of the vertex set such that
no two vertices in i are neighbors in g
so for example here all the colored
vertices are an independent set here
because there's no none of them which
have an edge between them and here this
is not an independent set
okay so um
so the study of these independent sets
is of
great importance in combinatorics but it
also arises in other fields that as
i will mention
but our one parameter family of
probability measures on independent sets
where this lambda
parameterized by this positive
real number lambda which is often
referred to as the activity
is what the hardcore model is so in the
hardcore model on a finite graph you're
essentially
giving a probability to each independent
set that is proportional to lambda
to the power of the size of the
independent set
okay so um any subset has sort of this
probability distribution as long as an
independent set it's just simply lambda
to them so the higher lambda is the more
weight you are giving to sets that are
larger independent sets so often you
know you send lambda to infinity to try
to understand what maximal independent
sets is but that's not what my focus is
going to be here
so okay so you know as is well known you
can write this really explicitly in
terms of this proportionality but the
hard thing is that you cannot quite
compute
this z lambda for even moderately sized
graphs
okay so what do we want so here's a
family of probability measures which in
this particular case i call this is a
markov random field on this graph which
is the same as an undirected graphical
model
okay
and
another way to think of this you can
think of it in terms of independent sets
but maybe what will be more useful to us
is to think of it really as a
configuration of 0 1 to the v so you
think of each vertex taking a state 0 or
1
with the constraints and this is where
the hard constraints comes in where the
neighboring vertices the sum of the
states of the neighboring vertices must
be less than or equal to one
and so there's of course a one-to-one
correspondence between
independent sets and such configurations
by simply assigning to every vertex in
the independent set one and everyone
zero to the complement
okay please do interrupt me i know it's
even if it's remote but i can't see your
faces
so please feel free to interrupt me at
any time when anything is unclear or or
needs to go slower or faster thank you
okay so like i said said this hardcore
model arises in combinatorics it also
arises in communication networks when
you want to assign channels which have
to be a disjoint different frequencies
which cannot overlap in wireless
networks um and the name comes from
statistical mechanics where it's a model
of hardcore lattice gas
where each occupied site is supposed to
be a fat molecule that repels other
molecules
and there are many other applications
but what is the question that we want we
want to start to see can one estimate
the parameter lambda of the model by
just sampling from this distribution
and so of course i think most people
would say yeah of course you know just
just sample many iid samples from the
model
and you know simply use the law of large
numbers and you use sort of standard
likelihood based estimates to provide
some kind of consistent estimators and
of course we're interested in the regime
whether
where the size of the graph is really
large
but really our question is what you can
do with far less information you know
it's getting iid samples from these
things is is not often available and
it's not something that we want so we
want to really focus
on the question that if you fix a known
graph jn on n vertices and then you give
a single sample from it
from this hardcore measure you don't
know what the lambda is you do know what
the graph is
is there a computationally tractable
estimate for the parameter lambda of the
model
okay
so that's that's the question that we
want to try to answer
so a standard approach would be simply
to take the maximum likelihood estimate
however this is computationally
intractable due to the normalization
constant c lambda g that i mentioned
so instead
one could try to take what is called the
maximum pseudo-likelihood estimator
which was introduced by bisag way back
in 1974 75 and the idea of that is if
you're given a certain sample so you're
just given one omega samples on each of
the vertices which i'm just always going
to label from 1 to n for simplicity
and u um sorry this is missing this
should be the arg max
overall lambda of this what is this this
is called the log pseudo likelihood
function and what is it it's a product
form
and of course we know that even though
the normalization constant is hard so we
cannot compute probabilities we can't
compute conditional probabilities in a
tractable fashion so the idea this f
lambda i for each vertex is the
conditional probability
of the state at vertex i given the
states of all the other vertices
okay
so you have these uh this conditional
probabilities which you you sort of take
a product over all i and the idea is
okay this is a pseudo likelihood
estimator
um you know there's no a priority reason
why
you think that this you know looking at
the arg max of this rather than the
maximum likelihood should work but um
you know basic did show that this can
work
well in certain situations so
uh one thing that we
wanted to look at is to try to see how
well this works in this context
so i should mention that and i have
given references at the end that people
have looked at these kinds of the
maximum pseudo-likelihood estimator
based on one sample
um for easing models so these are the
soft models um ferromagnetic models and
so but the
structure of
of um models with heart constraints is
very different
so let me explain so
let me first tell you what is a result
that we have in the case of the hardcore
model so like i said you've given some
graph on n vertices you take a single
sample
and then if you define your
cn is just to be it's counting so it's
just the number of vertices which have
one so it would be the size of your
independent set if you want to think of
it that way
and then u n sigma is a
another count of vertices
which are zero and have all its
neighbors zero
okay you can and what is so special
about these vertices well the thing is
that if you count each of these vertices
these vertices are those that if you
change the value from either 0 to 1
then they would still be an allowable
configuration so that's why i call them
the number of free vertices or sort of
unconstrained vertices and that's why i
have u and c is sort of the count
so u is sort of free unconstrained
vertices where you could change the
value and you would still get a
legitimate configuration in the sample
signal
okay
and it turns out that in the hardcore
model if you if you work out these
conditional distributions and look at
the arc max
the maximum pseudo likelihood estimator
in fact takes a very nice form in this
particular case which is just the ratio
of the number of ones divided by the
number of free vertices
okay
and um which is it's rare to have such
an explicit form so that's really nice
in this particular case and it is at
least intuitive because of i mean that
you would um that this should be larger
if the number of ones are higher then
your estimate for lambda hat for the for
the lambda would be higher if the number
of ones were higher and you know sort of
uh that at least makes sense uh that
it's proportional to cn in some way okay
so then uh the the theorem is that so
this is the estimator that you have in
the hardcore model
and that if you consider a sequence of
graphs that has uniformly bounded
average degree so that you look you know
you just have average the degree of each
vertex in the graph
and if that is um finite the over the
uniformly finite
then this estimator lambda hat does
actually converge to the true value but
also at a rate so at the at a rate of
sort of square root of n can so m over
square root of n so it gets square root
of
n to the minus half close to the true
value as the n gets large
okay and this is for any sample you're
just taking one sample and you're trying
to get uh the value of the lambda
okay
any questions
okay so if you look at uh i mean there
of course all bounded degree graphs will
satisfy this condition but also
realizations of random graphs like
sparse error any graphs and things like
that would also satisfy this condition
of a bounded average degree
okay so this is just sort of the start
of just looking at one particular
example
but um let me tell you a little bit
about the the idea of the proof so you
look at the sort of log pseudo
likelihood function check called nlp for
to be short and remember that these were
the conditional probability mass
functions of sigma i given the rest
and
you obtain this lambda was the arg max
right you have to so essentially you
just have to compute the derivative of
this show and then this is random now
because you have the sample but you want
to show that it is very concentrated
around zero as the true model parameter
so for those who are sort of used to
some of these kinds of inference
questions for markov random fields you
might worry that
is this really possible even in the case
when the
associated
marker random fuel or the infinite graph
doesn't have a unique
gibbs measure or in other words
when you are when there are very strong
correlations
and you don't have correlation decay in
your system uh on the graphs between
configurations and different vertices
you have very strong correlations then
you know sometimes you think that
inference might be hard but in fact here
because we don't use correlation decay
which is often used in this case to to
try to get concentration but we use
another method of what's called
exchangeable pairs to show concentration
we're able to sort of get this
consistent
throughout for all activity values
okay so once you get the derivative you
show it's concentrated but then you also
need to show that it's somehow
asymptotically strongly concave and for
that you need to
understand and establish certain
properties uh so of course concavity is
needed to actually show its a maximum
right at that point but by establishing
and some some sort of uniqueness
uh is needed so for the strong concavity
and you do this by establishing certain
properties of the
limiting normalized log partition
function so the partition function being
that normalization constant c
and so
um that requires uh trying to understand
the the
behavior of the hardcore model
uh for large n
um understanding the partition function
okay so that was just sort of a a
beginning to try and see whether these
kind of pseudo-maximum likelihood
estimators are likely to be useful for
hard constraint models
um and
so then we wanted to try to understand
more generally whether you can do this
kind of parameter estimation for more
general classes of hard constraint
models so what do i mean by you can sort
of formalize what is a hard constraint
model in the following way
you take the set of states that you have
so in the hardcore model it's just zero
and one
and you construct a graph on the states
if you allow a zero to be next to itself
then you have a loop so you put an edge
between zero and zero
you allow zero to be next to one in the
in your cons it's not in your sort of
configuration space so neighboring
vertices can take values 0 and 1 then
you put an edge but you don't allow a 1
to be an x2 1 so there's no edge between
1 and 1.
okay so this is what is a
constraint graph
whose vertex set will be the number of
states that each vertex can take and the
edges determine whether the constraints
essentially so the more edges you have
the fewer
constraints you have in your
configuration space okay so in the
particular case of the hardcore model
right this was the constraint like i
said and then you can identify
this uh this the space of configurations
with homomorphisms from
the graph g
to this to the graph h
because then it disallows
um you know two neighboring vertices to
be one one because there's no edge over
here okay so that's another way of
thinking about where so by hard
constraint models we mean
uh uh con models where each particle
takes values in some finite state space
and the constraints are induced by this
kind of a constrained graph which
forbids
certain neighboring configurations
okay
so then we wanted to try to understand
what is the role of of this sort of um
so give me let me give you some other
examples there's something called the
widdham rowlandson model which is
comes up in
again statistical mechanics it's a model
of a binary gas where the two kinds of
gas particles which repel each other so
here it's one and two and zero is just
the empty site and so 0 of course
connects with everything but
2
cannot be next to a 1. so there's no
edge between 2 and 1.
so that can that has this h graph and
then there's of course a very well known
coloring models where you you can
if you have k colors
then here in this case you have
five colors and you can have any um
it's really like the complete graph is
the constrained graph you're just none
of them have loops
so you're not allowed to have a
two neighboring vertices with the same
color that's the only restriction and
that can be looked as the configuration
space simply homomorphisms from this
complete graph to and from the from the
graph g
to this complete graph
okay okay so that's these are we want to
understand this is now just the
configuration space but we're interested
in some
probability
measure on a family of probability
measures so again given some simple
graph g
and then you're given a constraint graph
which is not necessarily simple it could
have loops as i said
then an age coloring of g as i said is
just an assignment of the colors to g in
the like in the sense that i said that
you can't have neighboring vertices
which
don't have an edge in h
and then the probability measure so the
model that we're interested in
probabilistic model is just a
probability distribution and now you
have parameters
uh q minus one parameters in the
hardcore model you had one parameter
because you had two states here you have
q states and so you have
q minus one parameters and again the
probability distribution here your
of any configuration
is proportional to the product of lambda
to the um you know whatever the sigma uh
the
size of the number of uh configurations
of that size
okay
so given a constraint graph and another
graph gn so we want to again ask the
same question given a single sample from
the h-coloring probability distribution
is there a computational retractable
estimator for the parameter lambda of
the model and in this case another
lambda is a multi-parameter so it's a
vector
and it turns out that in this case
there's an there's an another quantity
of interest so we had the c and u r but
here the u is a little more complicated
so you can still think of these u as
these unconstrained vertices
which uh i want to think of them as that
if you swap them then they're still
allowable configurations and one way to
just write that
is just to say that
so there so here i have i'm looking at
with respect to
a particular um state okay in the in so
if i look at the state r
and i want to see whether this vertex is
free to change to state r then i need to
ensure that all the neighboring vertices
um you know are sort of in the
neighborhood of r
right so i was taking states that are in
the neighborhood of r and my constraint
model that way if i change this
particular vertex
v
to r
then i'm not violating any constraints
in the
constraint graph
so you have this quantity which is the
set of states of sort of i call free
particles with respect to the state r in
the neighborhood of v
and um then you note that this quant
yeah so
as i said i'll refer to these as our
unconstrained vertices in the sample
and just make a little note that
obviously since this is an allowable um
configuration itself so it is
this this count of these number of r
free vertices is obviously greater than
or equal to the ones that are already
taking the values r
so that's just something i just wanted
to observe so this is just the count of
the number of vertices which have state
r in my sample
okay
so
um if i fix a constraint graph this is a
minor uh almost any constrained graph
this is a minor restriction that i'm
going to do and then a sequence of
graphs that satisfies again another
minor restriction that you actually have
a feasible configuration that your h
doesn't make it impossible to have any
any configuration at all so you just
don't want it to be the empty set and it
has again uniformly bounded average
degree
then once again you have a root n
consist and now here you have the
euclidean norm here
in terms of measuring the distance
between the parameters
okay so then your maximum pseudo
likelihood estimate is again square root
of n consistent
okay
any
questions okay
okay so um
and so let me tell you a little bit on
the assumptions because now here i
didn't mean i should have spent some
time on this so here there's an it's not
remember in the for the hardcore model
we simply had only this condition on the
degree of the vertex but here there's an
additional condition that when i choose
the sample that sample should have a
certain property which which is given by
here which is
you know something that you want to sort
of deconstruct and understand what is
this um assumption saying that if i take
a large enough sample
that has this property when will it have
this property
okay so remember what this is saying
that the num the sort of fraction
because there's an n here so if i divide
this this would be the fraction of
our unconstrained vertices
you know should be of of a positive
order you know they cannot vanish to
zero okay so they so that means they are
of order n
for every uh okay so you can't have sort
of just some states having very very low
representation in that sample
and uh so the consistency result for the
h coding model like i said i'm going to
call this this this additional condition
a rainbow positivity condition for
deposit for following reason so you
remember that this was greater than the
count
and so in a sense if you could show
that the
uh expected value
of um
any uh configuration under your um
in your model in a in a neighborhood of
the true parameter
that the expected number of vertices
with state r
uh will be a fraction not number but
fraction of vertices your c bar is a
fraction then
if that is strictly positive as n goes
to infinity then you can show that uh
this strain this condition is satisfied
and we call this a sort of rainbow
positivity condition because that means
like all the states so all the colors
are represented uh you know with with at
least some
order
uh n uh
positive fraction
so
but you know that still is something
about the sample and you might just want
to say i want to understand uh it in
terms of just the model and i don't want
to be looking at the sample so it turns
out i you can't put a condition
on the constraint graph itself and it's
you can say that if there is at least
one unconstrained state in the graph
that is there's one vertex that's
connected to all other graphs all other
vertices in the constraint graph
then
uh you this rainbow positivity condition
is automatically satisfied okay so you
can check that uh and so that we had to
show using sort of studying these markov
random field models
and this is true for example for the
multi-state of course we know that the
zero you can always is something that
can connect to everything so it's true
for a hardcore also an extension of it
called the multi-state hardcore widdham
rowlandson models etc so this is nice
because it's just a sufficient condition
simply on
the constraint graph
and you know you don't have to look at
the particular sample and see what's
happening
okay so again the idea behind the proof
is you know to to look at this log
pseudo likelihood and now look show that
the gradient
is concentrated around zero
uh but the proof now of of showing that
it's strongly concave in this more
general setting is much more complicated
and it involves relating sort of the
hessian matrix to some other covariance
matrix of a certain distribution
and using facts about its eigenvalues to
show that it's negative definite
whenever the rainbow positivity
condition holds so that's where the
rainbow positivity condition comes in in
showing strong concavity of this at the
at the value at the true value
and in fact one can show that uh this is
this luxury i mean the gradient is even
one lip sheets
and that's very useful
because i didn't really tell you what
the estimator here was right in this in
this particular case for the hardcore
model i wrote it down explicitly but
in the case of more general
constraint models the estimator
is given sort of implicitly as the
unique zero or with high probability
unique zero of a certain you know quite
explicit function i'm going to flash the
form of the function but it's really not
important i just want to say that it can
be written down very easily once you
have
the
sample so it's just a simple expression
here where you just have to look at the
neighboring neighbors of each vertices
in that sample and and then just compute
something simply
okay um so you just have to sum over
the the vertex okay but because of this
you might say okay it's a zero of some
function but because of the one
lipschitzness in fact you can do a
simple gradient descent algorithm to
find the zeros because you're talking
about an algorithm that can actually
estimate this is not just an existence
result you don't you can have a simple
algorithm to actually compute this
well i mean to get close enough
okay um so i thought i should talk a
little more about
you know all the conditions so i as i
said that a sufficient condition
for in the general h
um
h h coloring models
um is that you have this rainbow
positivity condition and that a
sufficient condition was this nice
condition on the constraint graph
but
uh there's clearly one model that i
mentioned that doesn't satisfy this
right
for instance the queue coloring model
will not satisfy because every vertex is
constrained to not have itself
as a neighbor
so
you might think okay then this this
theory that you apply doesn't you know
apply to one a very important uh
you know where you want to
to estimate the parameters of a regular
coloring model or the k coloring model
but in fact we so that even though the
sufficient condition for the rainbow
positivity fails
and the rainbow positivity itself could
fail they what we show is that the you
can show that the mpl estimator for this
model
is still root and consistent on any
graph gn that has uniformly bounded to
neighborhood rather than just one
neighborhood
okay
so there's a little bit of a trade-off
here so
um
and i because of the lack of time i
won't have time to sort of explain
where the two neighborhood comes in but
i do want to talk a little bit more
about the trade-off
between you know the rainbow positivity
condition and putting extra conditions
on the graph
right so here i'm putting extra like i'm
looking and i'm saying well i don't have
this nice condition
on the sample or on the actual h the
constraint graph but then if i put
extra conditions on my sequence of
graphs then i do in fact
i'm still able to get consistent
estimation
so a natural
question in this context or
is that you might say okay so maybe any
age
coloring model
maybe
it will be consistent for you know a
small enough sequence of graphs you
could ask that question that you you
know if the rainbow positivity doesn't
hold can you just transfer it onto a
sort of stronger condition on the gn
so for instance is the uniform bounded
to neighborhood
enough
for all models without the rainbow
positivity
and the answer to that is no
and you can construct
a
graph like this so if you have an h
coloring model
uh this is the regular just so if you
have um
you have over here a um two uh vertices
here there's actually a complete graph
here and on q minus one vertices if
there are q states altogether so there's
a complete graph on q minus one and this
sort of in and it's a bipartite
structure so this gives a counter
example where you can actually prove
that you do not have consistent
estimation at all
so it's not just that you can prove that
you do not have root n but
root n constant you cannot have any
consistent estimator and of course you
might think that these non-existence
results are a little harder to prove but
the way you do it is um
by by showing that if you had a
consistent estimator you would need
certain hypothesis testing test one test
two errors to behave in a certain way
and you can prove that they they cannot
behave by studying uh the difference
between two models with different
parameters
okay so
so it's not possible to have consistent
estimation for all age coloring models
but we did show for the cue coloring you
can by just putting a little additional
condition on the gn the other question
you can ask
is you know in the queue coloring model
can we relax the uniform average to
neighborhood boundedness back to just
the one neighborhood was it just
you know why
can you get away with that because it
was okay for the hardcore model and why
do we really need the two neighborhood
boundedness so
we could also show that there exists a
sequence of graphs with bounded maximum
degree so it's bounded degree
um for which consistent estimation is
impossible so uh this is quite a simple
uh graph so uh of course it's a path
it's not maybe one that you would
encounter but it's just a counter
example so here you would have a sort of
a union of n disjoint triangles and then
a fixed
um
graph a line
graph of fixed size which is not
increasing with n
then you can easily see that the vertex
3
cannot belong to any of these
can can never be in any of these because
it can only be the neighbor of one
vertex so the state three can never be
found on these triangles and so they can
only be found here so the fraction of
these
three states is really going to go to
zero um i mean as as n goes to infinity
um and that's not enough of course it
just says that the rainbow positivity
condition fails but then you can show
that in fact consistent estimate
estimation is not possible and obviously
this is a graph which has
very nice bounded maximum degree of just
three
okay
so okay so uh just to conclude
that uh you know we can develop sort of
computationally feasible algorithms to
estimate parameters of graphical models
with hard constraints for a large class
of you know sort of sparse graphs or
bounded maximum degree graphs
and obtain in fact just even a rate of
convergence of the estimator as the size
n of the graph goes to infinity and
there may be other models besides the
hardcore model for which you know the
estimator has a closed form solution we
don't know but we can anyway compute it
using gradient descent for the class we
know
however we don't know uh you know
further conditions
be when the rainbow positivity condition
fails is there a more general condition
other than we just studied cue coloring
models so that's one question and maybe
another
more relevant uh thing for sort of
when you want to actually look at finite
size and a particular problem
of n we do get on the asymptotic results
and it would be nice to try and uh
sort of bootstrap our results more to
sort of get finite n accuracy estimates
so that you know how large the graph has
to be before you can get a reasonable uh
reasonably close to the estimate
uh to the true true value that the
estimate is good enough and the error is
small enough um yeah these are just some
relevant uh references of bessag was the
person who introduced sort of the
pseudo-likelihood method sort of
chatterjee used it
sort of
in the context of estimation and spin
glasses and then there were sort of
several works that tried to do things in
the context of federal easing models
and recently this has also been used
more in other contexts the
pseudo-likelihood
in using easing type models but coming
from
other
learning problems
and
this is the work that
i was talking mostly about
i think
i think my time is up so i will end here
thank you
uh guarantees i mean uh it looks like
you have no components uh
uh you know exchangeable pairs to show
the gradient is small etc like
yes uh yeah i mean i i think that it it
could be possible but what we were
trying to do so you know this is
somewhat recent work it's not like we
tried finite n very hard but it was
it's not completely straightforward
because there are um we use exchangeable
pairs to get concentration but there's a
lot more because you also have to
understand this concavity and the
concavity is also with high probability
as n goes to infinity and that's the
part which
hasn't been fine identized but we it's
it's certainly something that's doable i
believe
but we haven't spent enough time on it
that's why i put it as a question that i
think is doable and should be done
but we haven't yet done it
but it's not completely trivial it's uh
it requires a little bit more of
estimation
like i said that in the case of the
general age constraint models we you
know you have to understand better the
eigenvalue of this certain covariance
matrix and you need you know adequate
bounds on that
but i do think it is feasible
if